obviously music and dj is a passion of
mine but if you were to
be a dj if you were to be like if you
were to open for me say
my next gig what would be your handle
and what would be your
like your go-to sort of song that you
would play to like get the crowd like
pumped i would do i would be conezone i
would wear an orange
i would be able to wear an orange
traffic cone on my head oh you guys have
a theme going yeah i have an orange
traffic cone
so you're reflective i'm all about
directing traffic in another direction
you're reflecting people's images back
at them i'm trying to
uh control traffic flow and that is also
music flow
so i've got i've got an orange cone on
my head i'm conezone
and what i play over and over and over
again is the archie's sugar sugar
oh honey
sugar sugar
you are my candy girl
and you've got me and i go
and there's a part where it breaks i was
just going to ask if there was a remix
oh there's a rematch you're beat boxing
yeah is that what you're doing oh what
even is that what i'm doing what did you
think i was having an epileptic fit
no i'm showboxing i thought you
programmed those beats into the song
no i started beatboxing for real
mohammed so i'm like
oh sugar sugar you are my cat
oh yes i'm sugar i'm sure the pizza
sugar sugar sugar candy a candy sugar in
dublin gonna go
to your medicine then i'm wrapping and
um it's that kind of
slow aging white man rap um
i am conan i'm here to say you know that
kind of stuff that no one's done since
the
late 70s beautiful wow uh yes beautiful
and um crowd's angry yeah because then
you go back to sugar sugars
uh they're really angry someone throws a
pint glass at me
and it knocks the uh cone off my head
and people will start saying you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] but of course it's dublin so
they're saying you're shite
you're shy
and um they're i think they're giving me
the peace sign but they're really
telling me to [ __ ] off
because that means it's a whole
different meaning in dublin yeah yes and
i just keep thinking
um they love me and they're giving me
the peace sign so i
double down once again on the archie's
sugar sugar
and um then you have to come up in your
reflective gear
yeah and the first thing you say is i
don't know this man
he's not a friend of mine he is i just
showed up he showed up
just tonight and i have no idea where he
came from
yeah but then after it's over and people
have left you take pity on me and so you
and i
walk to your house where you live with
your parents right
yes would they would i be welcome at
your home 100
of course you would would your parents
even know who i am i don't think so
i'm sure they would be welcoming but
guess what
that might be for the best they wouldn't
know who dj conezone is
[Laughter]
well they'd be hearing about him then
because there'd be a lot of talk on the
local news in dublin
about some [ __ ] in a cone
who played the archie's sugar sugar nine
times and started a riot
brutally beaten brutally beaten brutally
beaten